[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hey, everybody.
It's Mark [INAUDIBLE], one of
your Talks at Google hosts.
How many people were
here for Amit Peled when
he was here back in September?
Okey-doke, OK.
Well, we're increasing
the presence
of strings on the campus now.
We're really happy to have
the St. Lawrence String
Quartet with us.
They are the
ensemble-in-residence
at Stanford, have
been since 1999.
And they tour.
And they talk.
And they teach.
And they play all kinds
of music, old and new.
And they play in
very entertaining
and profound and unusual
and typical ways as well.
They're all over
the map actually
as musical explorers
and performers.
And when we think
about classical music,
we usually think about the
three B's, Bach, Brahms,
and Beethoven.
And it occurred to me that Haydn
is actually the fourth B. BBB
and H, because H in the German
scheme of naming notes, is B.
And B is actually B-flat.
So all the three
B's are so flat.
But Haydn's the real B.
So we'll let the quartet
explain more about
why Haydn it is so important
and interesting, even
in these times, as well
as in his own time.
Now, I want to
introduce the players.
We have Geoff Nuttall, Owen
Dalby, Lesley Robertson,
and Chris Costanza.
OK?
So without further ado, the
St. Lawrence String Quartet,
Haydn discovers.
[APPLAUSE]
GEOFF NUTTALL: Well, the
great thing about Haydn
specifically is that he
rewards constant listening,
constant work.
I laugh anew every time
we play that movement.
And we've probably
played it 300 times.
So for us today--
and I know I have a mix.
How many string quartet
players in the audience?
A few.
Yeah, so there's
some hardcore people.
And how many people who have no
idea what Opus 20 Haydn means?
OK, cool, yeah.
That's about what
I was expecting.
So this whole thing started--
we play string quartet concerts
for a living, basically.
We guide the youth of
Stanford musically speaking,
I suppose, as well.
But years ago, we discovered
some really basic points.
And that was that we
liked Haydn string
quartets a lot more than our
students and our audience did.
And it was somewhat
frustrating because we
came offstage thinking, that was
the most incredible experience
ever.
This is such great music.
It's moving and
powerful and hilarious.
And the audience was
just like glazed over.
And the students never
wanted to play Haydn.
So we figured firstly-- and
this is sort of important--
we realized that it's
not Haydn's fault.
That was a first step.
Right?
And then it became,
so how do we get
people to get this like we do?
It shouldn't be that hard.
It was so frustrating.
Haydn, here's the
key in many ways.
Haydn, more than any
other composer, especially
Classical period
composer, works really
well on a number of levels.
So if you put it on
on the automatic play
thing at a cocktail party in
the background, it sounds great.
Everybody feels
slightly smarter.
And there's an aura of--
you know what I mean?
It works.
It really does.
And more and more-- and this
is a whole question of where we
are--
how does technology
affect how we appreciate
and listen and experience music?
Haydn, more than anyone,
benefits, almost demands--
if you want the hairs on the
back of your neck to stand up--
active participation, active
listening, following the game.
And we discovered
that the more that you
could open that window, whether
you're a music expert string
quartet player, or someone who's
coming from zero experience
with the genre, it's gettable.
And it makes the act of
listening and/or playing
so much more pleasurable.
And Haydn wrote these pieces
for that kind of involvement,
both playing and listening.
This is slightly boring,
but it's important history.
Opus 20 changed the musical
landscape as we know it.
Its influence is
hard to overestimate.
Let me just read
this, because it's--
well, when a famous
musicologist says something,
it somehow carries more weight
than a string quartet player.
This is Sir Francis Donald
Tovey, or Sir Donald Francis
Tovey, probably the preeminent
musicologist in history.
And this is over 100 years
ago he was saying this.
"Every page of this
six Opus 20 quartets
is of historic and
aesthetic importance.
There's perhaps no other
opus in the history
of instrumental music
which has achieved
so much and so quietly."
Back to the point,
many of you never
heard these before,
never mind heard of them.
But what happened, and what
he did in 1772 or so, really
did change music history.
You mentioned Brahms.
He owned the
original manuscript,
annotated all sorts of things.
Beethoven hand-copied all six
of these quartet parts himself,
arranged one for
string orchestra
before he decided to challenge
the genre and write his Opus
18.
Mozart, of course, was a close
friend and passionate follower
of Haydn, and knew these
quartets intimately
before writing his own.
So for something that had so
much impact on the greatest
musicians in history,
it's somewhat remarkable
that you don't hear
them that much,
and they have very little
impact on students.
So back to our original
problem, getting people
to appreciate and get
excited about Haydn quartets
like we do.
And so we came up
with this plan,
both for students and
audiences, that we
would go through a piece.
In this case, we're going
to play Opus 20 Number 2.
So please stay for the
end, because you'll
get a whole performance.
But before we play
the piece through,
we're just going to go
through each movement--
there are four movements--
and explain why we think it's
incredible, what to listen for.
Just giving you a
few little windows.
And it's amazing
how much just that
forcing yourself to
participate actively
in the process of music, instead
of letting it wash over you
and thinking about lunch,
which is fine in a sense.
You understand where
I'm coming from here?
So here's the model.
Haydn was so great
on so many levels.
But he both created the
form and the genre--
the idea of four people, two
violins, viola, and cello.
He created the structural form--
four movements, sonata form--
and we'll go there in
a second-- a minuet,
which was a dance form-- he took
from a country dance and made
it part of the concert hall--
a slow movement, usually a
song, and a final movement,
for the most part,
up until Opus 20,
was a Rondo or Presto finale
like the one we just played,
exuberant, boisterous fun.
So that's your model--
story, first movement, aria
or dance, second movement,
replacing each other, so
dance, song, and then party.
That was the model that he
set up himself and wrote
many quartets before 1772.
But Opus 20 totally changed
everything and on so
many levels.
And we're talking about
democracy a lot these days.
This is the first time where
the quartet really became
a totally democratic thing.
You'll hear Opus 20, Number
2 beginning, shockingly--
and I know for us, the
shock is somewhat tempered.
Up until this point,
string quartet playing
was tune, diva, backup band.
So what happens to
begin this quartet
signifies a really
cataclysmic change
in what the quartet could be.
So here's the opening
of Opus 20, Number 2.
[MUSIC - HAYDN
STRING QUARTET, OP.
20 #2, FIRST MOVEMENT]
So I love that.
What am I doing
at the beginning?
Nothing.
[LAUGHS]
And again, not
shocking at all to you.
I know.
But that would have been,
like, amazing for the players
and audiences of the day.
Cello solo to begin.
The viola's playing the bass.
And then, all of a
sudden, everything's
turned upside down.
The roles are changing.
And throughout this
movement, you're
going to hear that--
we're going to call this
the first theme in our story.
You'll hear that
played by everyone
in the group at various times.
So it becomes, as Goethe said, a
discussion amongst four equals,
amongst four friends, as opposed
to a backup band with star
soloist.
So the idea of
storytelling in music
is something that's really
important to follow.
And we're going to throw both
simple and complicated examples
and see how your
listening skills are.
[STRANGE WHIRRING SOUND]
Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, we played it Esterhazy,
where Haydn was lucky enough
to be a composer and
musician-in-residence
for over 40 years.
And leaf blowers were
not a big thing there.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a beautiful place.
So that's our first
theme material.
And what he's done is set up
the topic of cello as star right
off the bat.
So listen to what happens
next and that simple concept
of equal opportunity tunes.
So we've had solo,
me sitting out.
I get to answer, play the solo.
The next thing that
happens in measure 15
is Owen plays the solo.
I play the bass.
Chris is following along.
But he decides this
is really his show.
And listen to the pyrotechnics
that happen from this.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
Isn't that cool?
[LAUGHTER]
So within the first
22 bars of this,
you could look at it as a
beautiful, C major welcome
to our show.
This is lovely.
I mean, you as well.
But it's also suddenly, all
these things are happening.
So tune, not tune, answer,
answer, bass, discussion,
show-off--
it's all about me-- response.
Hey, I can do that too.
And this is happening.
So the difference between
letting this music
wash over you and say,
hey, check that out.
The cello is playing the tune.
There is the answer.
Bass, not, crazy lick.
And then your ears are attuned.
And what could
possibly happen next?
So to set up our story, in terms
of story, you need characters.
Right?
That first tune that Chris
plays is our first subject
or first character.
Later on in the
movement, we have what
we call our second subject.
And in this case, it's
in the form of a duet.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So Owen and I are one group,
and responding with the viola
and cello, Lesley and Chris.
So that's a totally
different type
of subject, but in the same
sort of world harmonically.
So to set this up so
you can nod knowingly
to your friends and neighbors,
we're going to play--
and you're not going to be
tested on this sonata form.
But it's really helpful
to follow along.
So what he does, it's called
the exposition, basically,
introducing the two characters.
You've just heard first theme,
cello, second theme, duet.
And then we get to the
end of the exposition,
and we're going to repeat
that material, just so you
can really get it in your ears.
You can understand
these characters.
Because what's
going to happen next
is what we call a
development, where
we start to dig deeper into
who these people really are.
So just so you
can nod knowingly,
we're going to play the
end of the exposition,
this first section.
And then we're going to repeat.
So just find yourself--
this simple act
of hearing this lovely
C major cadence.
It's great.
And then return
home to cello solo.
And just say oh, I get it.
That's the end of
the exposition,
and they're going to repeat.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
Were you with us?
I mean, it's really simple.
But it's hard to stress enough
how important those moments are
to get, to go, oh, yeah.
I get it.
Now, and this is why Haydn
is so great on another level,
the basic principle of
how it makes you feel.
So what's the vibe at
the end of that movement?
Pretty lovely, joyful,
everything's great today,
tremendous.
We repeat.
We're feeling good
about ourselves.
We've had these two
characters, but they're really
in the same tonal language.
So again, if you're
listening actively--
and it works on so many levels--
listening actively to
material, who's playing what,
and listening actively
in a way, it's simply
how does it make me feel.
Because in the end, that's
what this music is about.
So get that in your body.
We're going to play the
end of the exposition.
You're expecting
this lovely C major.
And of course it's
all about the set-up.
We go into the middle
section, the development.
And it's a different animal.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So what just happened?
Our whole world changed.
And again, if you're
not really with it
and living these
moments, that shock.
So specifically,
what just happened?
We went from C major to this
minor, devastating, scary
moment, unrelated, you
think, in many ways.
And this is where the
extra credit happens.
So here is what Chris
and I are playing.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So we're bashing at each
other back and forth.
Can anyone remember
where that may come from?
Because it's the
point of these stories
that everybody's connected.
All the characters turn
into something else.
Remember our first theme?
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
If you break it down,
just this moment--
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
And that becomes--
So he's taken what was a sunny,
lovely, joyful first theme,
distilled part of it, and
turned into this really angry
discussion back and forth.
He even sets it up as
a cadence at the end
of the first section.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
Just that moment in time.
And you can feel
the mind of Haydn.
Oh, that could become
something really scary.
Extra credit.
What's Owen doing here?
Check this out.
This is, like, insanity.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
[SCREAMS]
[LAUGHS]
I love that part.
It's so great.
Remember Chris's
crazy virtuoso lick?
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
It was joyful and exuberant.
But that stuck in Haydn's brain.
He said, I'm going to
turn that into fear
to accompany this duet.
So you think it's
totally unrelated.
And it is emotionally.
But it's all connected
and all ties together.
And that brings up
the big question,
technologically speaking-- how
much does the ear actually hear
these connections
when you're listening?
We get it.
And the question is, the
more you listen actively,
the more this
stuff you will get,
even if you don't realize it.
And the more you learn,
the more you dig,
the better Haydn
gets at effortlessly
combining these aspects.
OK, so we go through
this development.
And remember our second
tune, our second subject.
It was so joyful and lovely.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So that character comes back
in this development section
after this terrorizing opening.
But it's transformed.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
It's such a simple
concept to take
a character who is lovely
and calm and joyful
and turn it into something.
The same person who
you thought you knew
has now become nasty,
angry, and in minor.
And again, it's really
easy to describe.
He takes the tune, and
he turns it into minor.
But it's much more than that.
It's how does it make you feel,
and making that connection
with somebody you thought
you knew really well
turns around the next day
to be totally different.
And it's a simple
compositional technique.
But it's so powerful
emotionally.
Now, we're going to return home.
And on your test, this
would be the recapitulation.
And we're going to
set it up for you.
Here's the return home.
You're going to go, hopefully,
gasp knowingly, oh, I get it.
We're home.
We're through this
scary development.
We're back to this
incredible cello solo.
And this is where, again,
Haydn separates himself
from other composers of the era.
Normally, the recapitulation,
the return home,
would be an exact repeat
of that initial material.
So you feel good about it.
But already, Haydn's
brain is working.
So listen to what happens.
And see if you can
identify what's
different about our return
home than the original version.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So what happened?
AUDIENCE: You jumped on him.
GEOFF NUTTALL: I jumped.
Yeah, I love that moment.
It's like the diva got
shut down the first time.
But I was so excited upon
repetition of that first theme,
I said, I'm coming on
top of you this time
with the same little motif here.
You can just feel
his brain working.
And I love that moment
every time we get there.
So again, it's really simple.
Right?
You don't have to have
any musical training.
You can hear that as
return home, nod knowingly.
And then, what's he doing?
Why is he playing that?
He's not supposed
to be playing that!
That wasn't in the first bit!
And that creates a whole other
world, a different discussion
of that opening material.
So that's our story,
first movement.
And you're expecting at
this point either a dance
or a beautiful aria, a
tune that you can sing.
And this is what Haydn
lays down for us.
[MUSIC- HAYDN,
STRING QUARTET OP.
20, #2, SECOND MOVEMENT]
So he marks this movement
adagio capriccio,
so capricious in the fact
that it's not light and airy,
but quickly changing
in terms of character.
And the drama is
really Beethovenian.
This is one of
these movements that
shook the foundation
of music history.
This is romantic music 50
years before late Beethoven.
So what just happened
at that opening?
How are our ears doing?
This is a remarkable, yet
again, very simple technique.
Do we hear the
beautiful cello solo?
So we have this unison opening.
Right?
Everybody's playing the
same thing, C minor,
like a Greek chorus crying out.
And then what happened?
Cello solo.
Anybody hear what the cello solo
actually was in terms of tune?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEOFF NUTTALL:
That's pretty cool.
So here's our opening tune.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
And here's Chris's tune alone.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
GEOFF NUTTALL: Same, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEOFF NUTTALL: Isn't that cool?
But you don't hear
it as the same,
because Haydn has harmonized it.
And underneath Chris
playing that same melody
that wee yelled to the hilltops
becomes this painful, intimate,
supported by this harmony.
But it's the same tune.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
It continues.
Gets me every time.
[LAUGHTER]
So what happens next is really,
again, simple in description,
but really powerful
and Beethovenian.
That last bar that
we just played
doesn't actually
end how we ended it.
This is what Haydn wrote.
Here's Chris's last bar of solo.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So if you dozed off to
sleep at that point,
hopefully, you will awaken.
Again, the shock of not
just the dynamic difference,
the gestural difference,
this incredibly incisive
rhythmic gesture.
And that plays back and forth
throughout this movement.
Let's just do the middle
section, which is so great.
And this is simple expectation.
We were talking about this
earlier, like, with students.
Hey, theory, music theory,
I, V, I, the basic concepts.
You don't really
have to know it.
But you all feel it, even
if you don't think you do.
So here is a cadence in the
middle of this movement.
And you expect this.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So that's just simply as we
call it, V, G-major chord.
[PLAYS CHORD]
And then C minor
wants to go home.
[PLAYS CHORD]
So whether you know it or not,
as a group of active listeners,
you're really wanting
that to happen in the air.
And that's, of course,
not what Haydn does.
So have you prepared
your gasp of amazement?
[LAUGHTER]
It's something like--
[GASPS]
That will be good.
So here's that same cadence.
Again, listening
actively, feeling
it wanting to go back home
to that brooding C minor
and what Haydn shows us.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
I finally get my aria.
But it's both incredibly
beautiful and really weird
that it appears out of
nowhere in the middle
of this super dramatic,
crazy movement.
But again, if you're
not following the game,
it'll just all seem like a
lovely wash of string quartet.
And that's where, back
to my original comment,
this music can be either
devastating or just simply
lovely.
But you have to really take
part in the match, as it were,
to get it.
So expectation again.
Here's the end of the movement.
This cadence will be
familiar when we get there.
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
We expect.
And we get--
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
And we're in dance mode.
This is the third
moment, which arrives.
Does that opening
remind you of any--
no hint intended--
Scottish instrument?
[GROUP PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So he brings out the bagpipes.
So we've gone from Greek chorus,
beautiful aria, shocking loud
and soft, cadence expectation,
to this minuet with bagpipes.
And it's Haydn, again,
a little bit of history.
This is occurring right in the
middle of this galant period,
where music was really--
well, emotion bad.
Folk music, bad, dirty.
Complexities of Baroque
era, Bach and Handel, bad.
And in this one opus, Opus 20,
Haydn returns to all of that.
He reconnects to folk music.
He specifically reconnects
to the kind of human emotion
that was frowned upon
up until that point.
Within three years,
an emotional journey
like this capriccio movement
shocked the music world
and really wasn't bested or even
matched until late Beethoven.
And in a final movement--
get ready for it--
he writes a full
four-part fugue.
[LAUGHTER]
See, that didn't have the
effect I was really going for.
[LAUGHTER]
But remember-- I don't know if
you were here, or some of you
weren't here when we started.
That was a rondo finale, a
super fun, jubilant, joyful--
that was expected.
And to play a fugue
in this case--
and this is that amalgam
of technology and emotion.
And fugal writing,
of course-- and Bach
did it better than anyone else.
But Haydn is showing
off here in a way.
It's somewhat unprecedented,
because not only does he
write a four-part fugue.
The few has four subjects.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, thank you.
So again, some of you
know what a fugue is
and how it's put together.
Some of you don't.
It doesn't really matter.
But the subject-- or basically,
like in the first movement,
there were two
characters, two themes.
In this case, there are
four separate characters.
So to set it up
and just to sort of
sharpen your ears,
so to speak, we're
going to do a little exercise.
The first subject of
this fugue is the thing
you hear right off the bat.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So our first game is simply
to identify who's playing that
and in what order.
I'll give you a hint.
We all get to do it
once right off the bat.
Now, what makes this
challenging, of course,
all the other subjects are
going on at the same time.
So do you accept
your assignment?
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
OK, here we go.
[MUSIC - HAYDN,
STRING QUARTET OP.
20, #2, FOURTH MOVEMENT]
OK, how did we do?
What was the order?
Obviously, me first.
Who was second?
AUDIENCE: The viola.
GEOFF NUTTALL: Uh-oh.
OWEN DALBY: The viola did play
next, but not that material.
GEOFF NUTTALL: Ah ha.
OWEN DALBY: Ah ha.
AUDIENCE: It goes
from left to right.
GEOFF NUTTALL: Correct.
Yeah, again, it's really hard.
Because Owen's right.
The viola played.
But was playing a different
topic, a different subject
simultaneously.
So it's hard enough
to hear-- so it
was first violin, second
violin, viola, cello.
You all got that.
Now, the challenge is to
hear all these other subjects
happening simultaneously.
So the second character
is our second subject.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
Not the most incredible thing,
but it's a different flavor.
Third one--
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
And the fourth one is
easily identifiable.
It's sort of spiky.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
That's it.
[LAUGHTER]
So again, I don't
expect miracles.
But listening to
this fugue in a way
is really different
than listening
to polyphonic music, music
with tune and accompaniment.
It's mathematical in the sense
that you can do both-- enjoy it
as music and follow the game.
Who's playing what when?
Who has the first subject?
How are the answers going?
Where does it lead us?
And to make it even more--
well, crazy is perhaps
the wrong word--
groundbreaking, Haydn
says, sempre sotto voce.
So we always play
really quietly.
And that creates this
long-term expectation
of A, what's going on?
Why are we playing a
fugue in this movement?
And why are we playing
softly the entire time?
And what will happen?
Hopefully, you'll still be here
by the end of this performance
to find out.
So I think we've set it up.
This is Haydn,
Opus 20, Number 2.
Just for your future
listening and discovery,
six quartets in the set.
Three of them end with fugues.
Three of them end with
traditional rondo finales,
of which we played
one to open this set.
They all contained--
The frustrating thing is-- we
were talking about earlier--
we really want to just come
here and play all six and just
keep going, because
every turn, there's
something amazing and something
really moving and powerful.
And it's music that many of you
have never heard before, which
always sort of blows my mind.
So spread the word.
We're-- "evangelical"
is a little strong.
But it really does support the
kind of passionate advocacy
that we hope we bring to it.
Haydn is God.
[LAUGHTER]